so Donald Trump a radically abandoned
the NATO summit early yesterday and flew
back to the United States after being
ridiculed on camera by a number of world
leaders we already talked about that
yesterday I told you several world
leaders were caught on camera making fun
of the American president Donald Trump
it was Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau the French president Emmanuel
macron and trumpian British prime
minister Boris Johnson quick reminder of
that video
[Music]
so again the literal laughingstock among
world leaders it's not surprising it's
not new if you've been paying attention
so we knew the reaction would be furious
from Trump and indeed he was furious
throwing a tantrum then calling Justin
Trudeau two-faced which we'll talk about
shortly and then cutting short his
entire trip to the NATO summit and
flying back to the United States Trump
was scheduled yesterday to do a press
conference at 3:30 in the afternoon
local time canceled it and came back to
the United States when you elect a clown
you get a circus Trump of course
tweeting as if everything is totally
fine claiming another major victory in
the world of Bigley winning tweeting
just finished meetings with Turkey and
Germany heading to a meeting now with
those countries that have met their two
percent goals followed by meetings with
Denmark and Italy when today's meetings
are over I will be heading back to
Washington we won't be doing a press
conference at the close of NATO because
we did so many over the past two days
safe travels to all of course why would
you even this is like when he said he
got on the phone with Sunland and
demanded absolutely no quid pro quo it's
like why are we even talking about a
quid pro quo like if I call someone and
say I really need you to pick up my wife
but definitely don't kill her okay I'm
telling you do not kill her why are we
even talking about that much the same
way why is Trump even talking about the
fact that he's not doing a press
conference he clearly is very triggered
over listen in the end wasn't it just
locker room talk of sorts that those
world leaders were engaging in I am just
so sick of being a constant
embarrassment around the world by having
this man in the White House because the
office of the presidency has never been
more devalued the trade war is a joke
Trump's positions on NATO are a joke
it's all a joke and yet I dare say 60
million 62 million at least 55 million
people are going
to vote for this for another four years
of this in just 11 months that's the
scariest part of all of it and consider
how fragile the president is I listen to
a really interesting interview yesterday
Hillary Clinton appeared on the Howard
Stern Show yesterday might sound like a
weird conversation it was absolutely
fantastic I would encourage you to try
to find it if you're a serious XM
subscriber I think you can just see it
find it on demand on the app but
otherwise maybe it's floating around and
she very astutely talked about how she
had to sort of measure her reactions one
example that was given was don't know if
you remember the debates back in 2016
between Trump and Hillary but there
would be moments where Trump would start
sort of stalking in the background and
kind of standing close to Hillary
Clinton and she didn't react to it and
in the conversation with Howard Stern
yesterday she actually said I knew if I
turned around and said hey back off or
whatever the headlines would be she's
unhinged she's going crazy she can't
handle Trump how will she be able to
handle Putin or whatever consider the
fragility and trigger ability of Donald
Trump he mocks women people with
disabilities foreign leaders members of
the military including for the fact that
they were held as prisoners of war
political opponents he comes up with
nicknames for everybody and then just
because someone was critical of him he
leaves the NATO summit early calls
Justin Trudeau two-faced and then crafts
a narrative that really he won
everything and he's taking his 747 and
flying home did Barack Obama ever do
this policy differences aside can anyone
imagine Hillary Clinton ever behaving in
this way it's pathetic to a huge degree
but we've become desensitized we I said
it yesterday I think or the day before
as much as I try not to allow this to
happen
I recognize that a lot of this insanity
has become normalized because it's been
going on for three years at this point
or however long it's been almost three
years yes almost three years
we need to make sure not only that we
don't let the normalisation sort of
creep in as it has even for me but we
also are going to have to work really
really hard once this nightmare is over
once the the the mango Menace is gone to
get back to the type of political
discourse which wasn't any any beauty by
the way it had already been degraded
significantly but to get back to the
political discourse that existed before
Donald Trump and then ideally we could
go back even further although that will
be a much more uphill battle to climb
let's now talk about Trump caught self
congratulating on a hot mic the next
video is coming soon but before you go
to that please hit subscribe and like
we're running a test we believe that if
everybody does this this will hugely
boost us in YouTube's algorithm and then
everybody wins I'll report back to you
how this works make sure before you go
on to that next video hit subscribe hit
like thank you so much